au fait
mont d'or pour les fêtes contrer les
attentats terroristes surveillance
accrue dans les gares et les aéroports
le bouillonnement dans les universités
manifestation à nantes grève un peu
partout c'est le problème du
surpeuplement des facs
bob denard explique qu'il veut partir la
tête haute des comores la marine
françaises surveillent
mais elle n'interviendra pas crack
cocaïne et héroïne h tout s'achève dans
métro de paris c'est sur la ligne 9 pas
de la mairie de montreuil reportage
bonsoir et tout d'abord cette première
en médecine prénatale une première
médicale qui va intéresser toutes les
mères dans l'avenir
il suffira sans doute d'une prise de
sang pour connaître le sexe de votre
enfant si vous êtes enceinte plus d'amis
aux synthèses plus d'échographie
simplement une prise de sang une équipe
de chercheurs britanniques et italiens
vient de mettre au point cette technique
grâce à des techniques deux aussi très
sophistiqués les techniques de biologie
moléculaire
les progrès de la science immédiatement
perceptible dans la vie quotidienne
alala vous sur dix neuf femmes enceintes
12 attendait un garçon et 7 une fille
les chercheurs britanniques et italiens
ne se sont pas trompés pour la première
fois le sexe de l'enfant à naître a été
identifié à partir d'une simple prise de
sang effectuée chez la mère la mère on
le sait n'est porteuse du fait de son
sexe que de deux chromosomes xx x par
déduction
si l'on trouve un chromosome y dans le
sang maternel
cela voudra donc dire qu'elle attend un
garçon si on n'en trouve pas que c'est
une fille la logique est sans faille
mais pour faire ce diagnostic il y avait
d'abord un gros problème à régler
trop peu de cellules foetales dans le
sens de la mer et donc l'obligation
d'amplifier de donner de l'écho au
signal du chromosome y
le chromosome du garçon c'est désormais
chose faite avec les résultats publiés
par les chercheurs dans le land 7
aujourd'hui le diagnostic prénatal ne se
limite plus à la miod synthèse ou à
l'échographie c'est tout le diagnostic
des maladies liées au sexe comme
l'hémophilie ou la myopathie de duchenne
qui va peut être se trouver bouleversée
avec un large débat éthique en
perspective
si demain la méthode venait à se
simplifier encore pour un ton résister à
la tentation de savoir très tôt le sexe
de son enfant
la tentation peut être aussi de ne
garder que le foetus de sexe désiré
paris sous haute surveillance le
ministre de l'intérieur l'a annoncé hier
pour la période des fêtes la police va
surveiller particulièrement les lieux
publics et notamment les grands magasins
les gares et les aéroports
inquiétude des autorités les attentats
terroristes bien sûr et d'ailleurs cet
après midi le conseil de sécurité
intérieure s'est réuni à l'hôtel
matignon sur la présidence du premier
ministre michel rocard
c'est un conseil qui a été créée en 86
au moment de cette terrible attentat
dans la région parisienne loi and gas du
rejet explique comment l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle sera protégé
notamment par les douanes
aucun bagage n'échappe à la vigilance
des douaniers ici tous les passagers du
vol en provenance d'athènes doit se
plier à la règle valise sacs à main sont
soumis aux rayons x les passagers eux se
plie aux contrôles d'identité de la
police de l'air et des frontières
une sécurité accrue qui depuis ce matin
repose sur ces hommes deux fois plus
d'agents des douanes que d'habitude
les douaniers chargés de contrôle des
bagages assoute sur tous les vols en
transit et les voilà risque mission
vérifier qu'aucune arme
aucun explosif ne se cache dans ses
bagages en disposant d'un camion
spécialement aménagé qui permet de se
rendre auprès des compagnies lorsqu
elles le souhaitent pour que nous
procédions de vérification sont certains
bagages et le plomb également avec des
chiens formés à la lutte anti explosifs
et que vous avez vu vous verrez encore
tout à leurs cavaliers en zone de fret
c'est dans ce camion que les colis
suspects sont examinés aux rayons x
ici l'équipe de doignies simule la
découverte d'une arme autres moyens
d'investigation ces chiens dressés à
détecter des matières explosives
l'animal se couche c'est que le pain de
plastic et repérer autant d'attention
d'énergie déployée pour garantir la
sécurité dans les aéroports rassurer les
passagers et dissuader d'éventuels
terroristes
c'est le gouvernement a décidé de
prévenir ainsi les actes terroristes
mais qu'il les craint la menace depuis
quelques années hélas elle est
permanente le terrorisme est devenu une
donnée de la vie internationale
mais en plus il ya en ce moment quelques
indices qui peuvent inquiéter
hervé brusini la mise en place du
dispositif policier de paris c'est ce
rapport qu'il a largement provoquée
comme chaque trimestre le patron de la
dst bernard gérard a évalué le danger
terroriste qui pèse sur la france
et c'est à nouveau du hezbollah le parti
de dieu libanais pro-iranien que semble
venir la menace il y à trois semaines
ses 220 kg de ces quatre les explosifs
saisis en espagne était destiné à des
attentats en territoire français
c'est le chef présumé du commando
arrêtés à valence qui l'a avoué mohamed
ben haïti est proche du hezbollah
il a précisé qu'on avait demandé se
renseigner sur les voies de passage
discret de la frontière franco espagnole
les autorités ignorent si des explosifs
ne sont pas d'ores et déjà sur notre
territoire à chypre d'autres explosifs
ont également été découverts selon les
services spéciaux le destinataire
devaient être les réseaux hesbollah
d'afrique noire objectif probable les
aéroports les avions français
ces deux prises récente en espagne et à
chypre confiance ce que les experts
appellent une réactivation du hezbollah
les experts qui voient en iran et
surtout en syrie
les responsables de ce regain
d'activités terroristes
il faut ajouter qu'en ce moment même à
paris se tient le procès d'un terroriste
aujourd'hui à l'ouverture il a été
presque immédiatement expulsée et puis
il est revenu dans le prétoire
le tunisien habib marre marre et jugé en
ce moment par la cour d'assises spéciale
de paris
il est accusé notamment de l'attentât
contre le magasin marks & spencer en 85
dominique verdeilhan compte rendu d'une
audience agitée à aucun moment leurs
regards se sont croisés les amants sont
restés distants étrangers d'ailleurs
tous aujourd'hui essais par ma'a marée
dans le box des accusés
aissaoui elle comparaît libre vous
voulez mais toujours demande le
président trop long non depuis quand
depuis mai 86 autrement dit au moment
même où elle vient de désigner
son amant comme étant un poseur de bombe
à un geste qu'un expert psychiatre
qualifie comme un désir d'en finir mais
avec quoi se demande-t-il
avec le terrorisme ou avec un homme pour
aïssaoui c'est clair il y avait déjà eu
trop de victimes
pourquoi avez-vous commis ces actes
demande encore le président colons pour
la cause palestinienne pour un peuple
opprimé répondent inculpé là encore le
diagnostic de l'expert est lourd pour
lui maâmar est un personnage falot dont
les motivations sont plus utilitaire
qu'idéologique sefra subban hal dit il
tout droit sorti d'un libre
mammare n'a en fait pas grand chose à
nous dire
devant ce portrait peu flatteur aviv
mamar est resté silencieux
les regards des deux amants sont restés
dans le vague les facs en ébullition
rien ne va plus dans les universités
c'est la fac de nantes qui a fait parler
d'elle aujourd'hui 3000 étudiants et
enseignants ont manifesté cet après midi
contre le manque de moyens en personnel
et le manque de locaux symboliquement
l'université de nantes avait fermé ses
portes pour 24 heures sur décision de
son conseil d'administration
demain c'est le personnel non enseignant
qui entend manifester à nantes
en fait le cas de nantes n'est pas isolé
ce sont toutes les universités qui
s'agitent enseignants et étudiants
veulent attirer l'attention des pouvoirs
publics sur le surpeuplement et le
manque de moyens c'est le cas à lille
chantal kimmerlin noël alexandre
vérification et non ils ne se font pas
un gros câlin tristan issue s'ils
suivaient un cours d'anglais à 2 pour un
seul casque dans ce labo de langues
modernes un casque pour deux c'est la
moyenne ailleurs c'est une chaise pour
deux ou pas de chaise du tout à la fac
de lettres de lille c'est comme partout
en france le trop-plein l'asphyxient
construite dans les années 70 pour dix
mille étudiants
cette fac lilloise en compte aujourd'hui
vingt mille le malaise est grand
bien presque en traînant les pieds parce
qu'après on n'a plus aucun rapport
invite à un rapport de deux groupes
d'amitié affectif entre les étudiants et
ça c'est vraiment grave pour elle subit
une forêt pour tous et plus et pas la
fac et plus humaine étudiants
professeurs personnels administratifs et
techniques
tous sont d'accord on ne peut plus
continuer à travailler ainsi
c'est la désorganisation générale les
retards et les manques s'accumulent cinq
semaines d'attentes pour un polycopié de
cours normal l'imprimerie à cinq
employés de moins qu'il ya 20 ans la
côte d'alerté est atteinte la première
victime
l'université et la qualité de son
enseignement faut savoir qu'en première
année il y a encore quatre ans il y
avait 16 18 heures de cours qui était
assurée maintenant c'est 12 heures
uniquement donc la baisse d'année en
année ce qui fait que le diplôme le deug
de lettres modernes par exemple est
complètement méprisée dans cette région
au carrefour de l'europe l'angoissent
première c'est l'avenir il sera européen
ou ne sera pas la compétition est déjà
engagée et les comparaisons peu
flatteuses savoir qu'on est logique
qu'il faut et en belgique avec une même
nombre d'effectifs c'est à dire 1800 qui
l'ont 123 professeurs nous nous en avons
25 vous
j'avais honte déjà du diplôme que vous
avez décroché actuellement si les
conditions ne s'améliorent pas où est le
maquis sûr il ira jusqu'à paris avec
d'autres pour manifester son inquiétude
tractations en cours aux comores au
milieu le mercenaire bob denard au pied
du mur autour des villes la marine
française sur le pied de guerre dès
narda pris le pouvoir après l'assassinât
du président abdallah la france veulent
chasser des comores mais ce matin au
conseil des ministres le président
mitterrand a affirmé que l'idée d'une
intervention militaire était exclu
laurent boussier bob dénard l'a reconnu
il va devoir quitter les comores lâché
par l'afrique du sud est par la france
qui aujourd'hui travaillent ensemble
pour se débarrasser de celui dont elles
ont toutes les deux utilisé les services
il va devoir passer la main dernier
baroud d'honneur du vieux soldat il a
voulu se justifier et surtout donner sa
version de l'assassinât dans la nuit du
26 au 27 novembre du président ahmed
abdallah le président était toujours en
conversation feu nourri se déclencha aux
abords immédiats du bureau le
sergent-chef jafar fait brutalement
irruption dans la pièce et pointe à son
fusil dans la direction générale du
président et du colonel le conasur prix
fait un bond de côté alors que jafar
ouvrait le feu à tenir le président en
pleine poitrine
une version où bob dénard rejette les
accusations portées contre lui
une version qui pourrait faciliter son
départ l'afrique du sud a accepté de le
recevoir avec ses hommes temporairement
sur son territoire et les autorités
françaises poursuivent leur double
politique de négociations plus ou moins
secrètes et de gesticulations militaires
quatre navires de guerre dans lesquels
ont embarqué des commandos marine et les
hélicoptères ont quitté la nuit dernière
l'île de mayotte pour prendre position à
quelques km de moroni la capitale de
l'archipel
ce soir les négociateurs français
semblait optimiste sur l'issue des
discussions
alors que le gouvernement comorien et
les partis d'opposition se réunissaient
pour essayer de préparer les élections
présidentielles prévues au mois de
janvier prochain
malaise au parti communiste ce malaise
sera mis sur la table pendant les trois
jours qui viennent le comité central et
réunis place du colonel fabien
en l'absence de georges marchais
souffrent au coeur des discussions
un problème pas facile le changement
dans les pays de l'est
gilles leclair l'ordre du jour de ce
comité central le premier depuis les
événements à l'est est très chargé
aujourd'hui la politique demain les
problèmes constitutionnels après-demain
bien sûr le plus attendu les
conséquences des bouleversements à l'est
georges marchais convalescent n'est pas
présent mais l'appareil du parti paraît
bien décidé à contrer ce qu'ils avaient
pu critiquer l'analyse du secrétaire
général du parti communiste sur ces
changements
mais si la voie des contestataires et
des reconstructeurs se feront entendre
en demandant une mutation du parti
l'heure n'est pas encore venue ici place
du colonel fabien pour de profonds
changements
il ne faut donc pas s'attendre ici à une
remise en cause de la ligne actuelle du
parti communiste mais peut-être tout
juste à de léger frémissement
car il y a et il y aura surtout après
demain discussions et débats ici lors de
ce comité central c'est déjà positif 10
les contestataires déjà satisfait que
les communistes débattre de la situation
au sein des pays de l'est
frémissement aussi du côté des mânes et
le front tient mais c'est le marque qui
s'envole et surtout le dollar qui plonge
5 francs 89 à paris aujourd'hui
hier le dollar a passé la barre des 6
francs et il a continué à descendre
alors fini s'assied quelques
explications
est-ce que paradoxalement ce sont les
changements dans les pays de l'est qui
font baisser le dollar
oui tout à fait parce que jusqu'au 9
novembre dernier hervé delà de la
première brèche dans le mur de berlin
le dollar était la valeur vedette d'une
bombe
quant à la valeur refuge vedette du
monde occidental il est même monté
encore après les retrouvailles
spectaculaire entre deux berlinois de
l'est et de l'ouest
et puis ensuite et bien les marchés ont
renversé la vapeur ils ont pris
conscience que les événements à l'est
fournissez halal mal des perspectives de
croissance qu'ils allaient augmenter son
poids économique alors que dans le même
temps tous les chiffres indiquent un
ralentissement de l'économie américaine
le marque après un galop quitte à la
mesure de la vitesse des événements
auxquels nous assistons il a laissé sur
place toutes les monnaies y compris le
yen japonais contre lequel il a gagné
12% depuis cet été
alors pour nous français ce qu'il ya une
menace réelle sur le franc fayard une
menace c'est vrai la flambée du marc
avive les tensions au sein du système
monétaire européen mais le frank est
pour le moment défendu par des taux
d'intérêt élevés
et par nos bons résultats en matière
d'inflation lorsque caire vers et veut
voir affirme pas question de dévaluer on
le croit il vient même d'avoir le toupet
au beau milieu de cette tempête
monétaire de supprimer tout contrôle des
changes en principe dans les mois qui
viennent il n'y a donc pas de menace
majeure sur le front est
les choses peuvent changer de même qu'un
mouvement de reprise en main dans un
pays de l'est se ferait repartir le
marque en sens inverse
merci philippe les pays de l'est on y
vient avec la bulgarie le cinquième pays
où tout change le plus petit mais pas le
moins spectaculaire pour les changements
l'ancien numéro 1 jivkov a été exclu
aujourd'hui du parti dès hier on avait
appris qu'il y aurait des élections
libres en bulgarie patricia cost
tranquille souriante et triomphante
voici le charme discret de la révolution
bulgare loin des projecteurs dans un
froid sibérien avec un calme et une
détermination impressionnante
ils font pression depuis des semaines
simplement en manifestant leur nombre
dans la rue pour obtenir ce qu'ils
veulent
aujourd'hui ça y est cela tient en trois
points le nouveau numéro un pétard
mladénov vient de l'annoncer le parti
communiste à renoncer à son rôle de
dirigeant
deuxièmement des élections libres
doivent avoir lieu avant mais 90
troisièmement c'est la fin de l'ère dite
core todor jivkov que l'on voit ici avec
leonid brejnev vient de diriger la
bulgarie pendant 35 ans il est
aujourd'hui exclu du parti communiste
ainsi que son fils et tous deux feront
vraisemblablement l'objet d'une enquête
de la commission contre la corruption
qui vient de déclarer posséder de
nombreux éléments à charge
l'opposition bulgare qui n'existait pas
encore l'année dernière va devoir
maintenant s'organiser
et puis ça change aussi en yougoslavie
c'est nouveau effectivement ça fait
quarante quatre ans là cette fois c'est
l'enfant croatie je le vois sur mon
petit ordinateur un réformateur vient
d'être élu secrétaire général du parti
communiste de croatie et puis le parti
communiste de croatie a adopté le
principe du multipartisme est aussi
d'élections libres voyez ça change aussi
en yougoslavie on va au chili il va y
avoir un nouveau président derrière la
cordillère des andes
c'est en effet le candidat de
l'opposition patricio aylwin qui est
largement en tête dans les sondages
depuis vingt ans il n'y a pas eu
d'élection présidentielle au chili
pinochet va connaître un successeur même
s'il garde du pouvoir
bernard binlin et pascal stelletta ans
rencontrée à santiago un opposant revenu
d'exil
depuis peu de temps reportage
il est même autorisé
le rio mapocho et célèbres au chili dit
la chanson parce qu'il a ressenti à jour
c'est pour une tout autre raison plus
julio vega ne l'a jamais oublié 46 ans
ingénieur informaticien il a passé 13
ans de sa vie en exil avant de retrouver
son pays il ya tout juste deux ans
julio qu'est ce que ça vous évoque comme
image le royaume à poggio
quelques jours après le coup d'état il
ya eu deux cadavres qu'il se fait sur la
sur la rue hier et vous vous étiez ou à
ce moment là j'étais pendant quelques
jours chez moi pendant le jour où il ya
le couvre feu
j'étais caché oui et après j'ai appris
qu'ils ont levé le couvre-feu je vais
essayer de trouver un endroit plus sûr
vous mais où mes cachets et quelques
jours après on m'a arrêté
et on a conduit au stade national
qu'est ce que ça fait de vous retrouver
dans un endroit où on a passé deux mois
en détention
je pars c'est bizarre c'est la première
fois que je reviens ici depuis 16 ans ça
change on était là et a été plein de
monde
on avait un calcul à peu près dix mille
personnes vous prenez moi les premiers
de mois
c'est maintenant évident c'est autre
chose
et ce stade lieu de détention qui
devient centre de la démocratie
puisqu'il est transformé en lieu de vote
ça vous fait quoi on a attendu 16 ans on
a lutté 16 ans pour arriver à ça
justement en fait c'est la fin de la
dictature
mais ça n'est pas finalement un
raccourci assez saisissant de l'histoire
oui mais je crois que toute toute cette
histoire est plein de contradictions de
dragon c'est con comme celui-là de cette
période de sa vie
julio a conservé quelques solides
amitiés tous comme lui ancien détenu au
stade et au camp de chacabuco dans le
nord du pays
lorsqu'ils se retrouvent ils parlent du
retour de la démocratie
de cette période pleine d'espoir qui
s'ouvre pour le chili mais qui ne doit
pas pour autant faire oublier les années
noires de la dictature
on peut pas oublier une chose que le
peuple chilien démence et je n'ai pas
oublié deux paires justice de
d'éclaircir tout était fait revenir sur
toutes les les crimes qui ont été commis
pendant 16 ans non à l'impunité
châtiment pour les coupables se sont du
reste les slogans clé de cette fin de
campagne électorale au chili de toute
évidence la question des droits de
l'homme sera l'une des plus délicates
est réglée par le futur gouvernement au
rebond historique en afrique du sud le
chef de l'état le président de clerck a
rencontré nelson mandela le chef du
congrès national africain la haine c'est
interdit c'est mandela qui avait demandé
cette rencontre
une rencontre qui est accueillie avec
prudence par les noirs et en afrique du
sud l'opposition libérale blanche se dit
satisfaite de la rencontre mais
l'extrême droite trouve cette rencontre
tout à fait incongru d'autres
informations maintenant louis car
souffre
l'ambassadeur de france au liban rené
allard présenté aujourd'hui ses lettres
de créance au président haraoui cette
mesure qui traduit la reconnaissance du
gouvernement libanais par la france
est-ce que de renforcer le sentiment
d'isolement des chrétiens du liban le
président arabi a également reçu
aujourd'hui les ambassadeurs algériens
égyptiens
après nadia comaneci les douaniers
roumains ont laissé s'échapper 8 bergers
accompagnés de leurs 1140 moutons
bucarest a décidé de placer des douanes
sous l'autorité du ministère de
l'intérieur afin de renforcer la
sécurité des frontières
quant aux huit bergé ils ont obtenu le
statut de réfugié en v
inauguration aujourd'hui du colloque
écologie et pouvoir par le président de
la république et le commandant jacques
yves cousteau cette réunion qui
rassemble seize pays portera notamment
sur les cas les plus urgents tels que la
forêt amazonienne ou l'antarctique
déception pour paribas le pea lancé sur
la navigation mix est en passe d'échouer
paribas ne détient que 40 % d'actions de
la navigation mix dont le président marc
fournier a su organiser une défense
efficace
un coup dur pour paribas dont le
principal rival suez a réussi lui sont
dopés assurent le gros victoire il y a
moins d'un mois
les marchés financiers sont toujours
déprimé par les devises la bourse de
paris n'a pas failli à cette tendance
avec une baisse de 0.50 9% en fin de
séance la drogue dans le métro parisien
c'est en dernier on s'en est inquiété la
ratp a décidé d'ailleurs d'accroître la
surveillance ont parlé notamment de
l'arrivée du crack c'est un peu
prématuré semble-t-il de toute façon la
surveillance dans le métro existe déjà
sur la ligne numéro 9 par exemple près
de la mairie de montreuil là où le
trafic est le plus important
l'équipe d'antenne 2 accompagné une de
ces brigades de la police qui travaille
dans le maître éric perrin jean-françois
bernigaud ronde de nuit
la clé de la réussite l'effet de
surprise les policiers en civil
interviennent les premiers leurs
collègues en tenue viennent en renfort
sur cette personne il trouve une
seringue puis dissimulé un peu plus loin
le nécessaire du parfait toxico cette
personne là ne peut pas être poursuivi
quant à présent puisque le l6 126 et de
l 627 du côté santé publique prévoit que
seules les matières à substances
vénéneuses ou matière stupéfiante pour
être conduits devant une entrée de
police judiciaire
ce matériel là c'est pour un
consommateur mais nous n'avons pas
vont pas prouvé que l'individu cave et
ceci à les consommer 400 policiers
volontaires font partie du s&p sème le
service de protection et de sécurité du
métro et il y à 13 ans de 5h30 à 1h30
ils font la chasse aux voleurs à la tire
mais surtout à la drogue
ici ce qu'on appelle une bonbonne à
l'intérieur probablement de l'héroïne
autres fouilles
autre découverte de l'air dans une
enveloppe les preuves sont cette fois-ci
suffisante pour présenter le
propriétaire devant la justice le crack
un dérivé de cocaïne très puissant qui
ravage les états unis menacerait à son
tour la france menace sérieux certes
mais cette drogue restent marginales le
craquement parler comme ça existe à new
york sur le quai n'y en a pas il ya ce
qu'on appelle des cailloux c'est mal
raffiné c'est un mélange des speed si à
l'intérieur en ça prend pour vous même
vous en prenez non moi je touche pas à
ça pourquoi j'ai pu toucher à la coque
avant et les jardins du château que ça
fait mal mais alors se cacher que tu
ouvres le marché de la drogue c'est
aussi un marché de l'art n'a qu' il
n'est pas rare de trouver dans une poche
un bout de craie marin avec une lame de
rasoir les gars gratte nacré
pour en faire une farine le mélange soit
avec eux un peu l'aspect jco votre chose
un cachet et rasé et ils vendent soit
pour de bon tout cas sûr mais ils se
font avec ça à une dose vos deux enfants
peut pas parler de développement de
deux trophées de la drogue dans le métro
c'est un la drogue dans le métro se
déplacent c'est à dire que bon il ya
quelques temps c'était sur l'a3 et l'a4
à l'heure actuelle depuis quelques mois
c'est sur l'a9 bon lorsque nous aurons
pratiquement nettoyer à 9
nous n'aurons déplacer que le problème
le trafic de stupéfiants dans le métro
est le fait d'une centaine de personnes
toujours les mêmes le sps elle s'attaque
à l'offre mais la répression les qu'un
des axes de lutte contre la drogue avec
le traitement des toxicomanes et surtout
la prévention
les huîtres polluer dans l'étang de thau
dans l'hérault les élevages ont été
fermés pas de vente de ces huit car on a
trouvé des salmonelles dans les huîtres
part d'inquiétude toutefois pour les
consommateurs les contrôles ou le voyait
sont efficaces ils ont empêchés et ils
empêcheront la propagation des bactéries
coup de projecteur sur un dessinateur
formidable vous le connaissez tous il a
marqué notre époque fait signer 40 ans
de noirs desseins aux éditions de la
découverte
ward est sain c'est l'intitulé peut-être
parce que siné a été bien souvent
interdits pour son impertinence avec
aussi dans le titre cette phrase
pourquoi tant de haine leur new york il
t'a un petit peu d'ironie ladesou cbi
mario 40 ans de haine signer 40 ans de
travail sur tout seul devant sa feuille
blanche
il en faut du travail pour nous faire
rire la folie du monde un dessin contre
le front national et qu'ils soient
drôles les frontières montcalm et faire
rire parce qu'en fait mon boulot c'est
quand même plus les gens ont sous armée
police religion sexe et de gaulle
quelques dessins de signer qu'on peut
montrer s'entrechoquent lui
m
dites moi qu'est ce qui se passe ces
jours-ci quand vos ennemis traditionnels
change de camp par exemple quand les
deux plus en plus de communistes d'alès
qui ne sont plus communiste
moi je suis vraiment un peu déboussolé
là je me dis merde la faucille et le
marteau c'est un truc c'est quand même
beau la fois ci c'est d'être des paysans
le marteau c'est celui des ouvriers ça
m'embête un peu de tout ça soit foutu au
panier à poubelles qu'on n'en parle plus
et sylvie vont se vautrer dans le
capital il souffre dans le libéralisme
dans lequel on est franchement je crois
presse
bien sûr que je suis content ciné je
vous avais demandé un scoop le premier
dessin gentil plein d'amour pour
l'humanité le cinéma est fait j'ai pris
le temps pas eu de sens et pas eu l'idée
de plaisir et j'ai planché un peu j'ai
passé une heure ou deux
c'est vraiment rien trop et de présenter
à part les chats le dessin de chalon
le net
quarante ans de haine signer allons donc
40 ans d'amour de la vie oui un confrère
qui reçoit un prix littéraire cela
mérite d'être signalé c'est l'excellent
paul amar il vient de recevoir le prix
espace 89 pour le meilleur livre
politique de l'année pour son scènes de
la vie de province publié chez
flammarion le tchécoslovaque vaclav
havel a reçu aussi une mention pour ce
même prix il y à un tiercé demain alors
on voir les pronostics de pierrette brès
pour ce tiercé quarté + qui se court à
vincennes
le dif est le 19 le 6 le 18 le 9 le 15
le 11 et le 14
dans un instant c'est laurent cabrol qui
vous donnera lé pronostic de la météo ce
soir à 22h15 l'émission de claude
sérillon places publiques consacrées à
la nourriture biologique faut-il s'y
convertir réponse à 22h15 avec les
invités de claude plus tard juste après
ce sera à la dernière édition du journal
présenté par henri sannier bonne soirée
sur antenne 2 à demain 20 heures
à